Наша команда прочитала статтю Генерала
залужного і сприйняла її як керівництво
до дії декому вона не сподобалося але
треба навчитися розмовляти мовою правди
з дорослою українською нацією замість
солодкоголосої брехні єдиного марафону
народ має право на правду епоха оплесків
завершена ми відкоригували Наша команда
всю нашу програму і благодійний фонд
виділяє 50 мльнів на розробку засобів
радіоелектронної боротьби десятки
мільйонів на закупівлю fpv Дронів і на
вдосконалення оперативно-тактичних
Дронів і техніки розмінування Але я
впевнений Саме так має відреагувати і
уряд єдність - це є питання виживання
єдність навколо збройних сил і ми не
маємо права на політичні ігри хайп і не
маємо права на вибори в умовах такої
смертельної загрози не прийня коли
чиновники міністри чи окремі депутати
льють воду на млин російської пропаганди
час заспокоїтися і я вимагаю щоби ми
зробили висновки і прийняли закон яким
надати право головнокомандувичу подавати
пропозиції по зміну командувачів для
того щоби уникнути подібних поганих
ситуації Я вимагаю щоб ми нарешті
врегулювали ситуацію з убд Я вимагаю
поставити проект постанови
в'яніславського про відсторонення з
комітету національної безпеки безулої